toi en plus et il ya un truc aussi avec
toi on n'arrive pas il y aura vraiment
tout le monde et c'est savoir avec qui
tu es avec l'upa site amoureuse n'étais
pas amoureuse n'en admet qu à ding banon
mais amy schulman on n'y a rien avec
macho c'est mon pote vraiment oui oui
vraiment je vous jure que sur un truc je
leur ai déclaré mais ya rien a vraiment
rien dire aujourd'hui que célibataire
oui je sais le temps ça tourne sur les
réseaux ce qu'on appelle aussi de just
ryad aussi j'embrasse frérot voilà dans
mon père dont on l'a vu avec tout le
monde avait cru bon mais elle est
célibataire lâché là elle est dans la
musique est ce qu'elle est dans l'air du
temps donc tout le monde forcément leur
était une aventure avec les uns et les
autres
bah oui mais vous vous avez été dans
l'air du temps vous allez l auto là il
faudra rendre leur vaisseau bratisla
boys un oui et ça se passe comment
l'argent ou gagner c'est votre mère qui
gère ou c'est vous la gérez enfin comme
je suis encore mineure il ya moi et ma
mère dans le dans l'eau c'est vous qui
prenez une décision mal à être toujours
d'accord après je suis très bien entouré
j'ai un rapporteur d'affaires un contrat
ouais bah écoute si tu veux que je suis
satisfait mais ce que je trouve
impressionnant c'est qu'en fait elle est
vraiment au centre de tout de toute
forme rétention en fait en ce moment et
je trouve ça vraiment super courageux de
sa part c'est de garder autant la tête
sur les épaules et effectivement un bon
entourage c'est super important
c'est ainsi témoin mais comme vous comme
tous les chroniqueurs peuvent le voir
j'ai ma mère mon père et tous qui
m'accompagne partout et puis c'est
vraiment super important faut prendre un
recul faut être super mature et wyden
franchement gère sa notoriété super bien
je trouve ça impressionnant et là sans y
jeter dans fan de en 2002 soit les crues